Dorothy Rubin awaits where did you get
the title no crueler tyrannies from
Montesquieu the philosopher by way of my
very enterprising editor at Simon and
Schuster and I thought it served very
well no crueler tyrannies than those
that have perpetrated under the shield
of law and in the name of Justice a
perfect title why that book you've
written a lot about this in the Wall
Street Journal a lot and mostly because
I came to the journal on the wings of
one case like this and I had an editor
in chief of the journal Bob Bartley who
instantly recognized the importance and
of this event that was taking place this
sweep of false accusations of child sex
abuse and he recognized that there was a
larger issue here called prosecutorial
zealots that is runaway prosecutors who
quite simply in many cases don't care
they don't really care if you're guilty
or not guilty and you will never give up
the conviction and all of that
runaway prosecutorial zealots combined
with the pathos of the cases of
Americans citizens most of them almost
all of them middle class lower middle
class people who got up and saluted the
flag and who genuinely kind of believers
in our society and believed in law and
believed that if you are falsely accused
of something our system of justice is
there for you and you will be rescued
someone will come forward in every case
I wrote about these citizens said it's a
mistake someone will come forward and
they believed it to the end before we
start in any of the cases maybe 15
seconds on each one I mean then we'll
come back to it let's the Amaral's who
were they the emeralds they were caught
up at the height of in 1984 which may
seem like a long time to people ago to
people
but it really wasn't 1984 1983 1982
began a great great sweep a tidal wave
of faults mass abuse that is 20 school
teachers accused there was the famous
McMartin case in California
well prosecutors all over America picked
up on nursery schools that was with the
great thrust of all of these cases where
nursery school teachers childcare
workers all of them was somehow accused
of being a part of child molestation
rings for heaven knows what ends and
there was something called the National
Child Abuse Act
so government poured money into agencies
that went out to look for child abuse if
you pour money in you're gonna find
child abuse they've created jobs for
workers to go out and find child abuse
anyway the Amaral's
an italian-american of family run by a
woman who had been on welfare violet a
mural pulled herself up clawed herself
up into this marvelous position brought
up two children alone very successful
child abuse a child agency and people
relished getting their children in there
suddenly one day there was an anonymous
phone call it was Labor Day 1984 she was
advised that her son Gerald her adult
son had been accused of molesting a
child in 1984 and indeed in some places
still now you don't need any more than
an accusation gerald was immediately
taken away two days later to prison they
got him out on bail
no one confirmed the accusation no one
did anything as time went on and a
pattern was established in all of these
cases and this is typical of the
Amaral's
mrs. Amaral was then in her late 60's
she was then accused her adult daughter
Cheryl she was accused it was alleged to
be a family conspiracy to molest
children
they were arrested they were convicted
in two separate trials that were given
enormous sentences gerald Amaral being
the male and you have to understand it
is the rule in all of these cases that
gender matters a few of them male you
were seen as a major perpetrator
although if you were a lone woman as
Kelly Michaels was the weight falls and
you anyhow they were sent away to prison
and I began writing about them after
mrs. armor-all tits and and her daughter
had both served about six years and
Gerald had served eight years and a
couple of day a couple of months after
the first piece hit The Wall Street
Journal
they were the women were released on on
a plea and Gerald was kept and there
began our fight to free Gerald the
prosecutors fought and fought and fought
to get the women back into prison and
they almost won but by this time the
publicity that had been generated by the
writings about this which were taken up
later afterwards in the Boston Globe and
everywhere was so great so enormous the
tidal wave of of investigation into what
really happened prior to the Amaral's
had been my very first encounter with
this entire matter I was working as a
television commentator I was at wwo our
TV in New Jersey doing three times a
week some sort of media criticism and I
looked up at the screen something like
that and I saw this woman in her 20s
late twenties rosy Apple cheeks innocent
accused of something like 2,800 charges
of child sex abuse so I thought well
that's very odd but I didn't think any
what do I know I did I was never
interested in work in schools or
teachers it never occurred to me but
something seemed odd about this and you
know when you're a journalist if there
is a story that seems very strange in
paradoxical
to you there comes a point when you
still get a little click in your head
that says okay I see how this bizarre
thing happened how it's possible I never
got this quick I thought how can one
woman one young lone woman in an
absolutely open place like the childcare
center of the church in New Jersey that
she worked for
how could she have committed these
enormous crimes against 20 children
dressed and undressed them and said you
know do this to dress and undress even
one child every day without getting
their socks lost 20 children in a
perfectly public place torture them for
two years frightened and terrorized them
and they never went home and told their
parents anything cover them with peanut
butter it was alleged and she licked the
peanut butter off made them eat feces
made them drink urine terrorized them
this did seem strange what was her name
Kelly Michaels Margaret Kelly Michael
where is she today Margaret Kelly
Michaels we we did get her up and she
won on her first appeal and today she
lives with her four children and has
just delivered a fifth child with her
husband former prosecutor one of the few
people that I wrote about who has put
her life together
so in so healthful away and without
being haunted because once you under
false imprisonment of this kind and
remember there is no one more despised
no one then the alleged child molester I
mean the Amaral women when they were
thrown into prison you could not have
imagined people more used to comfort
upright status they were churchgoers be
thrown into a prison on a dirty mattress
while they waited being moved to their
cell that people spit at them
call them child abusers and these people
were invariably thrown into isolation
cells for their own protection I want to
come back to I want to just get a little
bit on each one of these people grant
Snowden grant Snowden as they would say
in one of
local papers hero police officer which
he was Miami police officer watered all
of his life to be in and police finally
made it though he was short too short he
stretched himself accused because he had
a quarrel with a fellow police officer
of sodomizing a child it was such an
absurd contention on the face of it that
even the Miami jury and this was all in
1980s in the early eighties they refused
to convict him but here's the other
aspect of these things prosecutors will
not accept well even when a jury says no
they came back with newer charges and
newer victims and the victims got
younger and younger because you can
inform little children with a lot more
persuasive memories of abuse that never
took place than older ones ultimately he
got six life terms and he is now out
Patrick Griffin Patrick Griffin Patrick
Griffin was a much-loved physician in
Manhattan some of this doesn't bear
telling just because of its
stomach-turning
aspects but Patrick Griffin was accused
by a patient who was angry at him for
not helping her with a phony lawsuit
against some institution of sodomizing
her while he was performing a
colonoscopy upon her and anybody who
knows anything about a colonoscopy knows
that the nature of what goes on what
remarkably revolting things happen and
the idea that this man committed oral
sodomy on her
in any event Patrick Griffin was
convicted and by the marvel marvelous
talents of his appellate lawyer he was
able to prevail they had a second trial
anybody who ever gets to a second trial
is in great danger because these
statistics will tell you a jury is going
to convict you something like 60%
of all people who go back but not in
this case it was something too grotesque
all of these people I'm telling you
about are haunted by all of this and
then there were the people in Wenatchee
Washington where there was a wholesale
pursuit by one lone detective who
decided he knew what child abuse was now
this was in the 90s so it's sort of
extended and he became the hero of the
small town of Wenatchee Washington and
most of the people he picked up were a
welfare client people on welfare who
knew nothing who had poor lawyers no
lawyers and they were all supposed to be
part of a sex ring where people climbed
in and out of a church every one of the
stories that I am telling you about was
brought on convictions that no sane jury
would have credited on evidence that was
simply incredible to behold there were
all the same kinds of pieces of evidence
because in all these cases prosecutors
had an interconnected link of
intelligence the same charges in every
case they had clowns bad people dressed
in costumes children were made to watch
animal sacrifices I asked you in how
many places so it was nonetheless the
case that the prosecutors in every case
said this case is different it's not
like these other cases in every case all
the evidence was the same that's because
I have to stress this they had expert
witnesses and the expert witnesses would
travel from trial to trial to serve the
prosecutors and they all came up with
the same list of charges now you can ask
yourself why did the jury believe these
things how would the jury believe that
is in the amur old case old mrs. emerald
one of the most upright of citizens had
suddenly turned at the age of 67 into a
child molester who raped children she
was accused and convicted of inserting a
stick into the body orifice of a little
boy tied him to a tree star
naked in front of everyone in front of
the house and in Massachusetts and the
children all tested to this the ones
that were part of the case who would
believe this but if you have a
prosecutor who tells the jury here are
all of these brave children these brave
children have come forward to ask that
you credit their story because they have
endured so much suffering and if you
don't do this you're betraying the
children it is not easy to find a jury
that is stalwart enough to say hey you
know this really is a pile of nonsense
John Carroll John Carroll upstate New
York owner of a boat Mariner who simply
had no no school business or nothing
your wife mad at you a woman who's angry
at you a separated wife and also the
sense of rumor the case you speak of now
John Carroll is the kind of case that is
much more often now heard you're not
going to find because of all of all that
we know now you're not going to find
people in schools being walked out and
masked the way they did in the 80s and
chained together you're going to find
husbands angry at wives wives hangry at
husbands bitter divorce cases in which
the most powerful weapon is child sex
abuse that was never true before the
1980s now it is the weapon of choice and
anybody can be accused and in this case
mr. Carroll was convicted the evidence
was grotesque two detectives who
appeared on the stand to testify that
they could tell from his body language
that he was guilty
what was the body language these two
detectives know well he held his legs
like this and he moved forward it meant
he was looking at the door all of this
all of this impressed the jury in
upstate New York the same prosecutors
witness that testified in the 80s to the
Kelly Michaels case
her theory being that as a child says no
no no nothing ever happened was the
absolute proof that something did happen
and the jurors bought that she was here
to say that roughly in the same way
again
how is it you could ask the prosecutors
could pick for their expert witnesses so
discredited an expert as this particular
one Eileen Tracey was her name
she had been denounced regularly people
wanted nothing to do with her because
prosecutors want to win they call one
another up and they say hey I need an
expert witness call Tracey will get it
for you that's the way it works what I'm
saying is an ugly truth I think most
people I think apprehend prosecutors
have among them some many honest and
people who know the meaning of their the
integrity and uphold of it but others
many others simply want to win their
cases and will go down to their last
breath when someone has been acquitted
saying he's guilty
when dr. Griffin was acquitted by the
second jury trial and the judge in the
case said to his attorney why did you
even ask for a jury I would have had
this man acquitted in two minutes on a
dimension prosecutor in New York and the
Manhattan district attorney's famous sex
abuse unit called me the next day after
I wrote the piece about him and said
he's as guilty as sin there has to be
something in the capacity of in the
mental capacities of prosecutors who
know against all of the evidence they
want to hold on to their conviction and
so people are still in prison Gerald
armor alt is still in prison because the
state of Massachusetts won't let him go
because the integrity of their case he
represents their victory so you can say
what is one man's life he has been
locked up
everybody else is out he has been locked
up in the state of Massachusetts but
because the Supreme Judicial Court of
Massachusetts is one of the most
venerable institutions in the United
States it was formed immediately after
the Salem witch trials that is that old
nonetheless the the Supreme Judicial
Court of Massachusetts ruled that there
have been so many appeals in the
Gerald's case that time is more
important than justice we have to put an
end to this process this shocked many
many many people in the legal
establishment in Massachusetts so there
we are so how do you know I mean what
what sense do you have as I was reading
I was thinking huh why is Dorothea
Rabinowitz right about this and why are
all these other people wrong I mean what
what there are no wrong they they they
know I knew the first that told me what
was wrong was the Kelly Michaels trial
is my first encounter with this in the
eighties the atmosphere was very like
the ayatollahs camp when I raised to the
television a news editor I said you know
we should do a story on this is
something wrong with this case and he
was a wonderful piece by a journalist in
the Village Voice Debby Nathan who also
raised questions the look on the face of
the editor was such that I knew you
you're not even allowed to raise this he
said don't ever mention this to me again
this is the most hated person in New
Jersey everywhere in the newsroom I went
I said you know there's something wrong
with this story how dare you it's the
how dare you I knew there was something
sacrosanct about questioning these
charges this should raise questions but
how did I know I didn't know I thought
well maybe the prosecutor knows what
he's doing so I asked to meet the
prosecutor glenn goldberg was his name
and he was happy to meet with me why
because i was no liberal person i was a
grown-up woman with a fairly
conservative at writing credentials
he told me how much evidence he had
against her it was nonsense he followed
me down the stairs after I raised the
questions and he said by the way now I'm
going to tell you the real evidence I
have against her what was that sir
he said she didn't wear underpants under
her jeans imagine I said what did that
mean he said don't you know that was the
kind of evidence how did he know they
they arrested her and I guess they found
out but the other thing was they sealed
the transcript what are they hiding when
they seal a transcript New York Times
went and asked in a desultory kind of
way the New York Times and a couple of
other papers went to court to open the
record and they said no I found my way
to the record I got somebody to open it
for me and that's when I knew I read the
testimony I read the entire children's
testimony and the interviews I saw what
the jurors did not see and here's what I
saw the children are interviewed they're
5 therefore they're frightened they want
to please this adult sitting in front of
them and they don't know what they're
there for
but the adult is suddenly showing them a
big doll and the doll has what is called
sexual sexual organ sexually explicit
organs and the interviewer is very
persistent and very nice and says to the
child do you want to help your little
friends helped do you want to tell us if
something bad happened what said the
children well you know something bad
happened and the child doesn't know are
they doing this by the way alone just
the two of them just the two of them
transcript being created that's right
you see they're so certain of their
virtue and the rectitude of their cause
that they let the tape recorders take
this down and they learn better later
they stopped recording these interviews
and they would hold up a spoon said show
us where Kelley molested you did
something bad to you a child has no idea
what's going on
the child takes the spoon and hits the
doll here where else child hits the
shoulder where else because it's very
clear to the child by now that her
answers are insufficient she's not
giving the question of what they want
there are where else is where else is
where else's until the child comes to
the sex organ hits the sex organ with
the spoon all the questions stop no more
where else's questioner has got what she
wanted and what he wanted what's
presented to the jury is only not this
Odyssey around the dolls head but only
Rachel showed us where Kelly molested
her with the spoon she touched the
genitals that was the kind of evidence
when you see I'm saying in cold print
the details of the questioning then you
know and you can't miss it why is it
admissible why is that kind of evidence
admissible because it was the it was a
kind of sacred truth and because this is
not here say they they produce the
prosecutors produce testimony from
children that they dragged from children
after hours of questioning and that is
simply distorted I assume though that in
many cases a child's right the child is
right by saying that's exactly where I I
was touched I mean in other words there
are cases were there are truly child
molesters oh there are always molesters
there but it doesn't ever come out like
this when there are real cases of child
molestation let's you can take what's
going on with the accusations with the
priests you know the malla station
that's going that is such a scandal
today I have no doubt that there are a
number of priests who are falsely
accused but I have no doubt that when
I'm listening to the testimony of these
children now grown up that these events
took place and what is the difference
one of the differences is there's a
record these people said something even
little boys went home and told their
mothers and their mothers went to the
priests and their mothers went to the
place
have officialdom the other thing is
there is no crazy talk about clowns
there is now talk about bluebirds being
slaughtered or being made to drink urine
you didn't need to fan safai any of this
he touched me he did this
there was a down-to-earth way of saying
this so I can vouch for the fact the
very good that these stories about the
mad clown molesting all of these
children that none of that ever took
place the first year the very first year
the very first time you looked up on
that screen and saw Kelly Michaels was
winning well here it's 19 I believe it
was 1987 I think it was that 1987 and it
took me two years to write to get
published published the first story
first piece of the Harper's Magazine
Lewis Lapham the editor-in-chief took a
chance and very quickly when everybody
else turned it down and they turned it
down for the strangest of reasons I knew
almost every editor at the time and they
were filled with commiseration they said
yeah but you know I have a four year old
child or I just can't do this because it
was a piece that didn't just raise
questions about her guilt that just said
this is an innocent person you know when
you've seen an innocent person that you
know because you've seen the record in
prison it's a life altering experience
she was sitting there in solitary the
two years did you go see her oh yeah and
I almost fainted and I don't think I
went to this one of the most secure
women's prisons in New Jersey and it was
a dismal and this well-brought-up highly
educated young woman was talking to me
about Einstein and I was about to pass
out looking at where she was it took a
long time but I did know that if I did
not do something about this life would
not really be the same were you did
anger and groans everything anger was
everything anger and horror but anger
was everything because the evidence was
so doubtless so overwhelming that these
children came in
knowing absolutely nothing about what
they were talking about and we're told
these words were putting their Mouse
they were told what happened to them and
they were drilled in what happened to
them and when they took the stand they
believed and that's exactly what
happened to all of these children go
back to the loo Lapham thing editor of
Harper's so I went through every editor
of The New Yorker this and that and
finally I said you know I've written it
three times for three different people
and they all in the end back out
somebody said wanted to try Lewis Lapham
he had called him up and did you know
him thank me you know in New York when
you're right you sort of know everybody
I think I once had met him and he got to
the phone and I outlined this story for
ten minutes and he said let's do it
amazed me let's do it we then sat down
in his office with a couple of his
editors and I outlined all of this and
he had I believe more response to that
story than in many many decades at
Harper and that year was 86 that was
that it was published in 90 I spent two
years trying to get a pub he was
published in April 19 1990 and you were
working where at the time I was then at
home I stopped working on television and
I was simply doing book writing
freelance stuff and I was just about to
join the journal but I wrote this before
the journal and with Lapham publication
of that we were able to move we got
money we got a lawyer one meaning I and
I did I mean I did and then I got the
wonderful lawyer Morton's Davis to read
this who is now deceased one of the
great liberal First Amendment not first
amend the civil rights lawyers and he
took some of his students at Yeshiva
University and they spent two years
putting together her appeal and they won
and she was out
and I will never forget that day when
the appellate judges you know when
you're going to argue and appeal this is
not like you're going to get the
decision right there but this was one of
those times when the appellate court
were virtually telling you that this
case is a crock but the prosecutors were
there and it was very dramatic the two
prosecutors that had brought these
grotesque stories about how all the
children went home and the evidence like
one of the mothers said my child doesn't
eat tuna fish anymore this is a really
important piece of evidence and what was
that supposed to mean according to the
prosecutors the smell of your smell of
tuna fish is very like the smell of
vaginas that was the level of evidence
at the appellate court we were no longer
in the state and the prosecutors I mean
you were no longer at the lower level
Court and the prosecutors started to say
Judge Arana children don't lie we'd
heard this a thousand times before and
the judges looked down and said who are
you trying to bamboozle you call this
evidence so we knew how many articles
did Lou Lapham publish in one article it
was one but it was enough it was enough
because it was enough everything was
laid out these are not subtle matters I
mean children who were told children who
would disrobed Kelly sang black magic
they were given magic juice drinks you
could not hear more fantastic stories
and yet in the courtroom when she was on
trial the children wanted to run to her
to kiss her do you run to kiss someone
who is so terrorized you let me before
you guys let me ask more about the
journalism of this because you do tell a
story in here where Edie Bradley was
sought after in the CBS law lunch room
yes who by my grant Snowden was the
Miami police officer you must understand
and I'm sure you do
everybody to whom this happens has a
family so it's not only the accused
that's taken down but everybody around
him all of his children Grant Snowden's
grief-stricken brothers could not
believe that their brothers were going
to be sent away his brothers going to be
sent away for life terrorist or
something they know never happened so he
got on a plane and he came to New York
not knowing where he was going and he
somehow found his way to the CBS
building carrying a sheaf of papers from
the trial and all of what he thought
would persuade someone and he somehow
worked his way into the CBS luncheonette
and sort of grabbed Ed Bradley because
they always looked on the media the
media actually helped bury the accused
but they were also the way out you know
as soon as there was an accusation in
the early eighties you did not have
reporters going around saying hey maybe
this isn't true what you had was night
after night after night on television
about the poor children and the monsters
Gerald amrold was considered and misses
a mural for the monsters and the witches
and life was transformed what happened
to Gerald is unique in the sense that we
live as they always believed in a
society where justice triumphs even to
the end they still believe that
something is going to happen the truth
will out and they were right except in
Massachusetts in Massachusetts as we say
the apples fall up not down every single
newspaper in Massachusetts but one every
important legal establishment and force
has virtually said he's innocent
not just said leave him alone they said
look it's clear that this is garbage but
they wanted to hold on to him Gerald
Amaral left was taken to prison when his
youngest son had just been born he just
got to know his daughters he missed
their entire growing up but you know
what is so moving about many of these
face
Kelly Michael's mother sacrifices and
the way life sort of absorbed this
trauma and they lived nevertheless they
had birthdays they had the Gerald
emeralds children wore the confirmation
closed so their father could see them
the girls are now 23 22 and the son is
18 but what but he missed everything he
missed every graduation and as it
happened he was one of those fathers who
lived for his children and still does
and then you're absolutely convinced
that he's totally innocent it's not only
I'm convinced everybody is convinced let
me tell you the Massachusetts governor's
parole board of Massachusetts is the
toughest Parole Board in the country
they have reason to be tough acts
prosecutors hard-nosed types they had a
special parole hearing for Gerald
commutation petition unanimously they
declared that he should receive
commutation a couple of years ago but
about a year and a half ago two years
ago the majority of the board then
issued a separate opinion that said in
essence this case is based on nonsense
and there is every reason to believe
that this person has been falsely sent
away this was completely unknown in the
history of governor's parole boards and
pardons that's how much everyone
understood about this case which has
been exhaustively looked into so he had
one foot in the door and was on his way
out it's unheard of most it's actually
unheard of in Massachusetts history that
governor would not listen to the parole
board which they issued a scathing let
me interrupt her because the governor in
that case was chained swear that's right
Jayne Swift though
Jayne Swift was fighting for a political
life she was acting governor she was
acting governor but she wanted to be
governor governor and Jayne Swift who
already had a terrible reputation as a
governor was advised by her
political advisors it would not be good
to allow Gerald Amaral town and she had
her twins she had her twins and where
were we in the year I mean she was at
primary she was in a was it a primary I
think yes I believe it was a primary it
was just just before she had to step
down we got the news a year ago that she
was going to do this she made the
decision that she knew more she had done
her own investigation the Board of
Pardons and Paroles had investigated so
thoroughly to make absolutely sure they
would make no mistake and there was
nothing anybody could do she overruled
because she was in the middle of an
election her own Board of Pardons for
which she was roundly word you know
attacked and she even the citizens of
Massachusetts even declared you know
they're outraged but you could do
nothing about this now put him back in
oh he's gonna get the politics trick
Jane Swifton was running against her
Mitt Romney was running against her no
Mitt Romney was going Mitt Romney came
later Jane Smith I forgot whom she was
running against she was running against
someone else she was she was in primary
she was like I remember a book you say
something she was sixty points down
that's right she was even in her own
party in our own party she was sixty
points down everybody knew she was gonna
lose but she said it had nothing to do
with anything
some weeks not many less than a month
after she made this political decision
she never got to run because Mitt Romney
she had to defer to Mitt Romney because
her own party saw her as so weak so the
whole gesture was for nothing
but you also had the other politician in
the end this whole thing Scott
Hershberger Scott Harshbarger was the
original he was the in 1980s he was the
original chief prosecutor he didn't
actually prosecute at the trial he then
went on to greater things he ran on his
victory of in the Emerald conviction in
the 80s he was advertised as the
prosecutor who would put child abusers
away he went on to become Attorney
General of Massachusetts
he did he was a Democrat he was a
Democrat and Jane swift was Republican
and Scott Harshbarger went on to become
president of common cause the good
government lobby and has never once
yielded in his belief he's to write
letters to The Wall Street Journal which
is not known the editorial page which is
not known as a left-of-center place
accusing us because of the things we
wrote about this case of trying to throw
child abuse back into the darkness and a
protecting child abusers and to ask
myself does this person actually believe
you could get away with the charge that
the editorial page of The Wall Street
Journal is out to protect child
molesters why would we be doing that
well you can't change the mind of a
determined prosecutor determined that he
will uphold his conviction and so there
we are what is one man's life you're
left with the question one man you know
I was always moved in the way I looked
at these people these families the
anonymous nature of this suffering
nobody knew the agony of these families
there was many other kinds of agony in
the world but the way they made their
lives the way they sort of held together
the way they went through every
disappointment and they also didn't know
how one one man sat who had done nothing
wrong in his life whose life was now
confined to this little bed I went to
visit him in prison
Gerald emerald yes what prison this was
in one of the Boston prisons I don't
think it was Plymouth I forgot which one
I there were three he's now in a better
one but I was allowed to visit his cell
before you do that do quickly violet
violet died oh that's her relationship
to Gerald she was the adored mother and
her daughter Cheryl she had two grown
children and mrs. emerald when she was
released and her daughter
released by a judge who granted the
appeal had to spend the last two years
of her life she spent two years in
freedom she was in her 70s by then and
the prosecutor spent all of their
energies on this case trying to put them
back into prison where is Sheryl today
Sheryl has made her life - Sheryl is in
Boston wonderfully enough the prosecutor
when she agreed that Sheryl would not go
back to prison made her sign an
unofficial not a binding statement that
she wouldn't appear ever appear on
television prostitute is very unnerved
and interviews being given by people who
are released how can you do that how can
you well that was a real question Boston
paper said what is she afraid of she
allowed her she she didn't want her
speaking on television when I came to
Florida the day that we knew that we
could take grant Snowden into freedom
after the 11 years he was not going to
serve his his life terms but he did
spend 11 years in these rathole prisons
in Florida the prosecutor who was by
then dashed and broken had only one plea
to the judge
Your Honor we would just ask that mr.
Snowden not talk to the television
interviews in the media and the judge
said I don't think we're here
to cut off people's First Amendment
rights in Cheryl's case in Boston it was
another matter the prosecutor had agreed
to allow her to stay out of prison now
you could say gee I wonder why is she
allowed to speak to newspapers was the
power of television is so great and it's
so intimate and she did not want this
woman this to stand there so obviously
innocent by then everybody knew to
remind everybody what they've done how
old would Cheryl be today Cheryl is
today she's in her early 40s
how old is Gerald Gerald is about a year
or two old he's about 44 45 he's
compiled a marvelous record going to
school in prison one of the things that
has made his life easy or easy her is
that everybody in the prison system knew
he was innocent they know this is one of
the many things I've learned about in my
involvement with these cases in prison
if someone on the outside someone in the
media if the media asked questions about
your case they begin to look at you as
not some kind of monster and child
predator that again said well maybe he's
innocent in prison they don't pretend if
they are child abusers that they are
innocent as Gerald and others have often
said there are guys here who really
molested children and they don't pretend
otherwise
and that seems to be true you went to
visit him whose last time you saw him
about two years ago I went in and I saw
there's a little bunk and on top of him
is another bunk and there's another bunk
in and I looked at it I said how could
he live how can you live in this way you
know was and he looked at me was such an
odd question in his eyes he said that he
said you know you get a lot of
advantages when you're a prisoner for a
long time I thought you think this isn't
Vantage's prison is so reduces your
sense of expectation when grant Snowden
in Florida first got word that his
wonderful attorney Robert Rosenthal had
actually managed to to win a habeas
corpus thing you don't get anything
harder than that and he was going to get
out what first thing that happened was
he was worried he was worried what would
happen to him 11 years in this horrific
prison and all you want to do is run
your concession candy stand hold on to
your job he was happy alright so the
expectations are shut down and you just
do what you have to do to survive guilty
or innocent but in prison Kelley
Michaels
who came with a lot of education and a
lot of spirit and a lot of spunk
she was actually people spit in her soup
and they did all kinds of things you do
it yeah after a couple of years we
thought she should be out in the general
prison population why her appeal was
being worked on and she made friends
people understood that there was
something that that this didn't happen
when Cheryl was released
Gerald Amaral's sister when the amarant
women were released Cheryl had to go
back to the prison for a minute the very
day of their release the entire woman's
prison population came out to cheer her
these are the same women that had
threatened her spat upon her years
earlier when she first came to prison
because they ultimately know that
something bad has gone awry and they
don't fool around let me ask you about
part about journalism before I get there
about yourself what yeah where did you
come from originally I came from Queens
New York and grew up and went to City
College at the at a time when the city
colleges in New York was sort of like
Harvard and what they offered and then I
went on I thought I would teach
literature that was a bad mistake I was
not meant to be an academic and I
quickly found that out and then I began
to write what year would you say you
began to write I see I know very well I
never planned to become a writer and
that's always been very helpful if you
don't plan it I planned it I plan to
become a teacher
I left graduate school I had nothing no
way of earning a living so I thought I
would go to work as a social worker and
a Home for the Aged and I hardly had any
idea then that this would give me this
had to be in 19mm middle 1960s and I
wrote a piece about the old people I saw
at this home for the agent and I had no
intention I just thought I'd just take
this down it was so it just drove me
was such an impassioned piece and I was
fortunate enough to have it published to
have the first piece you've written
published is a very good boost it was
published in commentary and it was
immediately after that but then
Macmillan company which we still had
offered me a book contract and we were
off and running but I'd never intended
it and here's what I learned from that I
often thought I'd if I ever did teach
journalism I'd like to say wait till you
have something to say before you decide
you're a writer because then you can
transcend everything do you get mad
enough if you get are pained enough
you're moved enough you're not going to
have inhibitions you're going to say I
have to tell this story and then I'll go
do something else I would not have
written any of that I must do I have no
idea how many pieces I've written on all
these people in the journal and journal
was remarkable and that every quarter of
the Wall Street Journal supported this
they allowed me so much space on this
but I could not have done it without
being impelled by pure rage of all of
the emotions that you have pity right
it's not that and you're not thinking of
the victims you're not thinking the poor
Gerald or poor friends that that's
behind you what you're thinking about is
the prosecutor what you're thinking
about is the totalitarian nature of this
enterprise
black is white two and two equal five a
child says nothing happened to me that
was the most continuously nothing
happened nothing happened nothing
happened it's never enough
well when they see it coming the
prosecutors did they say Oh God here she
comes
well the Amaral prosecutor didn't see me
coming because I was pretty new at it
they didn't know what I'd had to do with
the Kelly Michaels case they did not
know it they were in another state and I
called up and I you know you're a
journalist you have to talk to both
sides you have to talk to the prosecutor
and I called him and he was
be to come to the phone because his
experience mr. Harun he was the active
lead prosecutor his experience had told
them that the press was there for him
the press was there to carry his story
out in the midst of his telling me how
successful this prosecution had been the
Emeralds don't forget had been locked
away in prison by the time I got there
for many years it was a dead case they
were dead and buried as far as Boston
Massachusetts was concerned I know about
it because I knew all of the cases where
families had been slammed and there are
such a bunch of them and I said to mr.
hard doom did it ever occur to you that
this case could ever be overturned on
appeal and he said never never happened
well it wasn't overturned for Gerald but
three months later Cheryl and violet
walked out of prison and I remember by
that time everybody knew who I was and
what I had to do with these cases and
the press was very generous the local
press and they all there were crowds of
people from National Public Radio and
elsewhere at the courthouse this
wonderful little place in in Boston
where the judge was going to release the
women on appeal of Judge Barton and one
young woman the reporter said to me just
tell me how did you know because she
already knew I said what did I have to
know you tell me that this woman violet
emerald took a four and a half inch
butcher knife and insert this is one of
the pieces of testimony inserted it into
the anus of a four year old child left
no marks didn't hurt the child but you
could do that I said what do I have to
know what kind of expertise is all of
the charges or like this there was not a
single charge brought against them they
were so fantastic
Cheryl cut off the leg of a squirrel
stories change from minute to minute
with the children the children were
making the stories up because the
interrogators were saying if you don't
help me and tell me we're going to be so
disappointed you're going to betray your
little friends and this
these are literally word-for-word and
the testimony of this none of the jurors
ever saw this testimony and I can tell
you this several three or four years ago
in the effort to overthrow finally the
emeralds conviction which always failed
the court granted a special
investigation a special panel to go over
all of the evidence in this case and it
brought all the reporters in and for the
first time the reporters it's called a
finding effect hearing the reporter sat
listening to the testimony of the
children and I heard one of the
reporters scream as she heard one of
these lurid pieces oh my god do you hear
how great that oh my god in pulse that
reaction was of course the reaction of
every report of a finally heard what
really was in these interrogations but
no one ever heard it okay Harper's in
1990 you went to work for The Wall
Street Journal I did editorial page
editor all of this has not been done on
the front pages of the back pages in
their territorial pits right so what is
it you did that convinced Bob Bartley
when he was editor of The Wall Street
Journal that he wanted to put you on his
payroll and then let you do this
well nothing to do with this he had been
reading my other political work I was a
media critic and a tough one and one day
I just got in actually when he called up
and said how would you like to come to
work for the journal I thought he was
talking about Kelly Michaels that had
just been published in Harper's actually
he hadn't even read that it was the
other stuff I wrote about and I said
fine but two minutes virtually after I
got in to the journal I Kelly Michaels
was was there and I wrote about that and
he recognized what I'd done in that case
but it was not until I wrote about
Gerald the Amaral's and I won't forget
that day it was a it was in January 1995
that I first sat down to write about
this case and we were overwhelmed and
Bob came out of his office and said to
me this is fantastic
do another one
and publisher Peter cotton came down and
said I hope you get these people out now
mind you nobody asked me anything nobody
said how could you write about anything
so delicate and that was actually the
beginning after those first three pieces
the a week passed and the Boston Globe
sent its reporter down the most
important thing in these cases is that
the local papers take up these things
and when the Boston Globe came down to
ask me what I knew and to take to take
this on to we were up and running so
after they got what I gave them they
undertook a series of their own and
that's what had the impact do you think
given what journalism is supposed to be
if you were working for the front of
this the newspaper that they would have
allowed you to have this kind of
advocacy no absolutely the front of this
paper no I got tremendous support from
the front of the paper but it was the
editorial page they created a unique
thing on the editorial page then which
was investigative reporting carried on
in the editorial columns Bob Bartley had
himself done pieces of investigation on
yellow rain that old and so I basically
had carte blanche to go write and these
pieces were immense they lasted forever
80 inches 60 inches and it went on for a
number of years and I did my other work
there and I was the media television
writer and I wrote other editorials in
between but what really happened after I
wrote the first piece about Gerald the
Amaral's our readers of which there are
very many got really disturbed and when
I say the phone didn't stop ringing and
all they wanted to know is what can we
do and the same was true actually at
Harper's Magazine people have this
gut-wrenching feeling when they when
they read this stuff and so they began
pouring money in to the to a fund which
we didn't
but which I had our lawyers when I say
our lawyers I mean the the team of
appellate lawyers that I worked with on
all of this who are the the heroes so
what do you say to the person listening
to this and I read your articles if they
can't get Dorothy Rabinowitz interested
they're out of luck well that's what
they say but you know what the press now
is a very different press they ask
questions about these kinds of cases now
what I think is different in what I did
because I was able to do it you know was
to do all of the things like get the
lawyers get the money do it all and and
not just report well Gerald Amaral ever
get out of jail yes yes he will get out
of here his next appeal he comes up for
regular a parole next September and I
think you will get out there's only one
problem there's a little law in
Massachusetts and elsewhere called
sexual dangerous sexually dangerous
persons the prosecutor can even after
he's paroled decides she's going to keep
him there anyway as a sexually dangerous
person we hope it doesn't happen we
think she'd like to put it behind her
finally but you never know here's the
cover of the book and it's written by
Doris Rabinowitz is called no crueler
tyrannies published by wall street books
through Simon and Schuster
thank you very much thanks thanks for
having me